I'm Lindy boosted and I'm Christmas step
and were the co writers directors and
producers of this is ours which you know
life is all about the choices we make
what if we chose wrong so we'll and
Karen go to their summer home as it
enters into foreclosure and there they
meet a pair of iconic classic vagabond
so take them on the strange journey of
discovery / brink and hope so you some
film stars Carrie ganya or new Joseph
mark car and wonder Russell who many of
you probably know from Twitter ask all
the Wonder so you're doing something
interesting with the release of the film
while you're touring the film festivals
can you tell us yeah so we decided you
know a motto of our film is to kind of
break free and so we wanted to break
free of kind of the traditional way that
you go about film festivals and we're
doing that by we just had our world
premiere and I danced with films last
night and now today online at watch TI o
calm and TI o for this is ours you can
go and rent the film online for a
two-week exclusive online film rental
and in honor of the festival said I mean
we figured you know I means one of worse
things like when you go to a film
festival that people talk about a great
movie and then you're like oh cool where
can I see it the rector's like 18 months
or a year from now or whatever you're
like oh because by that point you forget
about that yeah so if you're like why
not utilize any momentum that we do have
from a screening of the film festival
people like the movie they tell their
friends and boom then their friends can
be like oh sweet i can just click i can
watch it you know this is exclusive link
and so you kind of had to know about it
from being at the festival and so people
feel like they're passing it on and yeah
we gave buttons that have the link on it
yeah and we get to build you know it's
the same thing like when you're doing a
Kickstarter campaign you're not just
raising money you're building an
audience you're building people who then
feel who are part of your filmmaking
team and they're you know they're your
advocates they can spread the word to
their friends at second center it's the
same thing like it's almost like
building a little street team out of out
of your festival experience with this
exclusive rental yeah
and specifically for me for the
filmmakers tuning in here how exactly
are you doing and how is how is it on
the site what are you using justify
which is I was kind of expecting to have
to wrestle with technology to get the
film up involved a lot it was just like
I click I don't know like five buttons
in the film was right yeah yeah super
easy and we just set a really low price
or oh my charging three dollars 48 cents
because we really just wanted to be
accessible we really want to build word
of mouth and get the film and how the
film reaches audience yeah they're
really trying to build an audience well
it's like because like you know a lot of
people who have said like well you know
if you put it online like your chances
of getting distribution are totally out
the window and although I'm like well I
don't see why it's a negative like now
potential distributor can look at that
and you're like oh well instead of
having a festivus reading where 200
people saw your festival screening where
400 people saw it and they liked it and
now they're telling people i think it's
just it i don't know who knows it's all
you know what day it is perfect figure
why not roll I mean we've rolled the
dice on this project so many times do I
guess we might as well ones will just
keep rolling dice you know that yeah and
are you only relying on the film
festival to get the word out or you will
at this are you actually promoting yeah
Jessica like this I work where I'm
sending out literally after we talk to
you I'm sending out to our 260
Kickstarter backers you know be like hey
this is a little thing we're also going
to kind of you know put it out there are
social media we're being a little bit
you know we're like it's not going to be
a direct link on our website or anything
so that if a film festival if they just
go to our website they're not going to
really find it right away you know I
think so we are trying to like play the
game a little bit but yes we're just
really utilizing that grassroots
word-of-mouth enabling our base that we
current have currently have to build the
base
so when did you finish summer home and
and then start shooting this is ours
right so yeah so summer home is May was
made almost like just a little over a
year ago yeah yeah so we guess we
finished somewhere we shot summer home
in May and then we shot this is ours in
august of that year that same year so
while we were on set with his as ours
our composer was sending us comps of
score so we're sitting there in our
motorhome on bazaars like listening
there yeah that sounds pretty good you
def ok so then we fit we finished post
on summer home right when we got back
from shooting this yes yeah and summer
home came from rehearsals of this is
ours or so actually last vacation which
was what mrs. ours originally was it was
a bigger script in a bigger film and
then funding and everything kind of fell
out and so we kind of you know mourn the
loss of that of having the consoles
going to an island and getting drunk
yeah it is I'm a wonder presented us
with summer home it's kind of a give up
on the horse kind of project which is
really great because she's just like you
know let's we lift our wounds lets you
know I have this idea that came out of
that rehearsal let's make it and so from
three weeks from that date we've made
the film and then we started rewriting
and rewrote the script for this is ours
and went into pre-production and to top
that in august of that same year do you
have tips for people on how to be
efficient and how to avoid time loose
it's really just I think pre-production
is just so important and just really
thinking through every possible scenario
because it you'll throw your plan out
the window on day one but at least you
thought through it and there you're able
to think on your feet that's that's how
we're able to be so efficient I think
yeah what else would you do you mean
like in the broader sense of time
wasting like you know I mean like the
articles we wrote for film cards like we
went a year without doing anything and I
was just cuz we sucked for a year we
just realized continue yeah well you
actually I mean we kind of just forgot
like you get into a rut of not producing
something and then all of a sudden you
know you like well I'm not gonna work on
something today well I'm not going to
work on something today I'm not gonna
and then a day becomes a week becomes a
month becomes a year um so just I mean I
you know just that idea of like try put
some effort into a project every day you
know and we knew going in and to not
make those mistakes again after we did
after our first feature we knew going
into this as hours and after summer home
we knew then we're going to go into this
desires and we knew going into this is
ours that we needed to start thinking
about what the metric was going to be
all ready and start writing that as soon
as we wrecked you know and so that's
what we did so that hopefully we're
writing the next feature script to
hopefully produce next spring God
willing if we get money and yeah and and
and we also made another short film in
December after wrapping emphasis ours we
were in the middle of middle of post on
that and inch up three days to work with
19 high school kids to make a short film
that premiered at the Seattle
International Film Festival just last
week okay so we did three shorts in a
feature lets here so
you